would you like to step inside the home
of a minimalist
well now you can you can take a video
tour of my family home
and ryan's home over at
theminimalists.com
resources
uh jeffrey asks how do i find a
supportive community if i'm not
religious
um i mean i think we kind of touched on
this but like
i think it depends on on where you live
and and what your interests
are but i think ultimately community
needs to be based on on values not just
interests because you might be
interested in bowling with everyone you
bowl with but like
i don't know if that makes for the most
meaningful relationship but that's your
only commonality
yep i said you know one of the things
that atheists are not great at is
creating community yeah for sure and
they're the worst at it yeah
they're not good at it i was talking to
sam harris about this and he was like
yeah
we're just terrible and so
i do look at the spectrum of what makes
you more individualistic what makes you
more communal
and so i'd say if you're an atheist and
you're religious fine uh
a place like mosaic where they just
basically tell you you don't have to
agree with us to be with us and you
don't have to believe to belong just uh
you need people
so when my friends were atheists i tell
them hey look man you know
if you if there's no god we can't hurt
you
you know if there is we it might
actually help you
but what you do need are humans what you
need our friends which needs community
so stop closing yourself out to people
who believe because they're they're
really good people there too
wow yeah you have a thought
i mean i like i play video games
that was one thing i picked up during
during the quarantine and i i play
uh video games with a bunch of like
creative directors in la which is
they like do post malone and and like
tory lanez and all these like other
dominic fights all these other music all
these musician uh
kevin your pa connected us and we play
call of duty but one of the things that
we find is like we none of one of them
on the other thing is like hey whenever
aaron comes on it's like it's pastor
aaron the language changes
there's less and i'm like guys you could
just be who you are and it is an
interesting thing to kind of
to see the switch happen when i come on
and but
it's like one of the few community
places where i'm like okay we all love
playing video games together
and we our values are so different and
yet we found this common place
and so we talk about faith and over time
now six months later
they're like hey you know can you pray
for me or hey this was going on my
family and i'm like oh this is kind of
cool like
yeah i'll pray for you but also like we
kind of found this place where we don't
believe anything the same but we
we have fun together we find joy so i
think that's for me
has been it is hard when you're outside
of a church or you don't play sports or
xyz but like
find people you can just laugh with and
and express your joy with
yeah and and and i do things with people
that i don't enjoy like
you like certain things i don't like and
i just suffer through them but
you come to church sometimes suffer
through that and then we'll hang out
before after and